[Music]
to be able to sing like that that was a
1990 concert Rome featuring the three
tenors and a 198 member Orchestra led by
famed conductor
Zubin Mehta it was the first time the
tenors had performed together after
reportedly turning down at least 50
previous off offers while the concert
helped make the trio international stars
it's just one of many career highlights
for Zubin Mehta last year he announced
plans to step down as music director of
the Israel Philharmonic Orchestra a post
he's held for 40 years jamie wax sat
down with Maeda before one of his final
u.s. concerts at Carnegie Hall at 82
years of age Zubin Mehta still conducts
with the vigor and passion that have
brought him worldwide fame I have to ask
you where do you get the energy the
energy is love the understanding of the
music you're not just a conductor who
uses the baton or the hands it's in your
face it's in your body it is my
profession to communicate
Zubin Mehta was born into music his
father was the founder of the Bombay
Symphony Orchestra in India I heard
music in my home before I spoke so I
don't remember what I sang first or
spoke Gujarati my mother tongue and I
went to a Jesuit School in Bombay where
all the teachers and priests were fans
of my father so they would ask me for
tickets for his concerts did that help
you or hurt you at the time no they
still failed me sometimes certain
subjects major left Bombay to study
music in Vienna by 21 he was filling in
for maestro's around the world
throughout the 1960s and 70s he would
conduct the Montreal Symphony Orchestra
and Los Angeles Philharmonic Orchestra
in the 80s Mehta served as music
director of the New York Philharmonic
and was named music director for Life of
the Israel Philharmonic
orchestra did you feel ever any
prejudice against you for either your
youth or the fact that it was unusual to
have had one from India never never
one of the great things about playing
who Zubin is that you're not just
playing with somebody was a wonderful
conductor but you also playing with
somebody who was a personal friend
internationally acclaimed violinist
Itzhak Perlman first played for Metta in
his early 20s and I've never seen such
energy before just with a you know I
think it came to the first Tootsie
oh the Tchaikovsky concerto and he
started to go like that and I said oh my
god this is good stuff
Herman estimates he's played for Mehta
more than any conductor in the world you
know that many conductors or fine
musicians and so on and suffer but that
little that little element which is the
communication between the musician and
the conductor sometimes is missing and
then you have somebody like Zubin you
know it goes and then it just goes like
that and catches him over his six
decades of conducting Zubin Mehta has
received accolades ranging from a
Kennedy Center Honor to a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame
what are you proudest of what memory do
you hold most dear
well the Israel Philharmonic is like no
other orchestra today in the sense that
they lived through crises political
crises every few years and it makes no
difference to their work schedule public
comes as usual the last crisis we had
was when Hamas would throw regular bombs
on Tel Aviv not one concert was canceled
public came every evening and when
sirens went off we stopped then we went
on again
[Music]
major remembers taking the orchestra to
India when diplomatic relations between
the countries were restored 25 years
after the 1967 war with its at permit
the orchestra played without any fee nor
did it suck receive anything and for me
was a kind of culmination to take my
orchestra to my country Zubin Mehta is a
living example of musics unique capacity
to bring countries and cultures together
don't ever underestimate the power of
music in general I'm not talking only of
classical music people are listening to
music all the time and it does make a
big difference just imagine a world
without all this impossible for CBS this
morning Saturday Jaime whacks
Ryu
you